Terminator 2
the t1000 roll that's a gift because
that's that roll is gonna be with you
your whole life such an iconic
performance and I'm told that you had an
interesting audition for that role you
know I remember when you showed up in
that movie that's like this guy is
absolutely fantastic and so scary and I
love the the fact that you could your
your body was molten metal you could
turn into anything but so much of it to
me was your expression is what sold it
and the lack of expression jazz straight
on dead stare well that was pretty much
what the audition was you know Jim they
he he didn't let me read the script and
I got to meet a guy and they put me into
this room and he he said they're gonna
set up a camera we just want to see you
ad-lib and improv and see how you move
and we want you to create this intense
presence and I said okay I'll do that
and I said so you know what you do is
put the camera on my back I'm gonna
stand out in front of the camera and I I
said I'm gonna I'm gonna go for it and I
just spun around and I looked into the
lens and evidently Jim saw that and he
was watching the audition take City it
kind of freaked him out a little too
that what's the best camera right there
let's do three just look at the camera
three and just keep your 25 I know a lot
to ask for but I mean this guy right
here yeah sure why not well I I guess I
could do it for you I got to kind of
focus a bit
Hey and you wanted nice and tight real
tight and real tight keep that head
looser keep your head loose and watch me
alright ready ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I got
you